[Music]
you tweeted a photo recently and I
follow your tweets and you did a photo
of you and I think it's from childhood
very sweet photo I think of you what do
you mean you think it's from childhood I
sometimes dressed up as an 8 year old
boy it was you after a really good
night's sleep yeah and there was only a
black-and-white camera around it is made
from choice sweet what a sweet boy you
are yes I was I should just say that's a
long time ago that's the sixties and you
shouldn't do that you shouldn't have
your picture taken well as cute as they
are you shouldn't do that with monkeys
anymore but we knew no different fake
come on little monkeys well there might
still be but you shouldn't you shouldn't
indulge that because they're not right
they should be wild monkey should be
running up trees and things really yes
that's what they do I like it when
they're in clothes on our court no don't
do that I've got a [ __ ] everyone likes
that but they shouldn't they'll never
learn to smoke a cigar and I know we
have to teach them these things that's
the gift we bring to monkey that's the
evolution yes somehow to put on little
shoes and do funny bits yes they are
very trust us were you the youngest you
the youngest in your family yeah that
wasn't a picture of me and my brothers
and sisters by the way I was the
youngest in my family I think by much my
locks yeah my next brothers like 11
years older then 12 my sister's 12 years
older and my older brother about 13
years older I'm I remember asking my mum
why that was I was about 11 eating my
corn flakes and I said um why my brother
was just so much older than me and she
said because you were a mistake
and I and I like I started laughing at
the honesty yeah yeah yeah that's
fantastic that's why you're in combat -
you are your siblings funny yeah yeah
they are I am the older brother the next
to me Bob is just always mucking around
I think that's why I got it from right
but he has no filter
you know like lumps or careful about
what I say he's here careful yeah yeah
wait a minute I want to hear about Bob
if you're the careful I know what Bob is
doing uh is that well there's one one
thing I remember he's a paint on a
decorator and he got a job painting the
weapons mr. research establishment in in
in England and he's in the van with his
guys that work him he's always showing
off and making people laugh and he's
they say anything and as they were going
in this store policemen with his on had
to check underneath with it you know the
stick on the mirror yet there's no
grenade yeah and as he was doing that
his helmet fell off and 20 cigarettes
fell out on the floor right and the
policeman just being nice to my brother
said I bet you've always wondered what
we keep under our helmets and my brother
went I knew it wasn't brains
and sort of everyone laughed and the
policeman went where are strip search
you on the way out but and my brother
did this job and then waited for the
copper to dawn waiting all night to get
away
Wow unbelievable you have a lot of fans
online who have become obsessed with the
idea that you look like cats are you
aware of this it's a thing that's
developing I think it's because I tweet
pictures of animals as well so I think
someone put two and two together said
yeah yeah it's odd isn't it there's
everything on the internet there is
everything on the Internet I thought
some of these cat pictures actually were
quite convinced that's a good one it's
the next one let's see let's keep going
and then then there's three there's
another one right here and we have
another one here
and then I think is one more I believe
oh that's I don't know I just like I
like that oh my god those are the
selfies you do right that we've done a
bit with those Weezer not lost on ones
here we go in a bath together I don't
remember that no no do i it probably
didn't happen then you know it didn't
happen there's no way that you and I
took off our clothes and then got into a
bath towel and I was wearing American
boxers and you were wearing European
speedos you do remember it really well
don't you I was on your lap keep your
hands on the table
[Laughter]
[Applause]